hey guys it's max today we're gonna be
comparing Dells brand-new 2019 XPS 13 2
& 1 with Intel's latest 10th generation
ice Lake chip the chip they've been
waiting for for a long time with Apple's
2019 13-inch MacBook Pro both these
laptops are pretty SPECT out and the
MSRP s are identical but we'll talk
about price in just a little bit because
it does get interesting we'll be taking
a look at the build quality the design
the displays keyboards trackpad speakers
the CPU and graphics performance and
more so let's go ahead and start out
with the exteriors and the macbook pro
is thin and light but if we stack both
these on top of each other you will
actually see that the new dell XPS is
slightly shorter and a little bit
narrower and as far as thickness the XPS
is a little bit thicker because it has
these little feet that stick out a
little bit more and the lid is also
slightly thicker as well but overall
both on the size and the weight the XPS
is smaller now I'll be honest I do
prefer the look of the MacBook it is
more of a squarish design with flat
edges but with that said the XPS is also
excellent especially for a Windows
laptop as an all aluminum design and the
base here has actually etched out of a
single piece of aluminum so it's very
rigid we have these nice shiny aluminum
edges over here aluminum lid it is very
nice it feels nice to the hand and it is
high-quality now we also have this hinge
which is a mix of materials but we also
have a little in um over here and that
shows the two in one design but I'll
talk about that in just a second taking
a look at the right side the MacBook Pro
gives us two Thunderbolt three ports and
a headphone jack whereas the Dell XPS
gives us just one Thunderbolt 3 port and
that's because we do have the higher end
for Thunderbolt 3 port model and then on
the other side once again the Mac Pro
has two Thunderbolt 3 ports instead of
one but the Dell XPS does give us a
microSD card slot which is really nice
now if we go ahead and open it up we
also have a little bit of a difference
here the Dell XPS has this kind of a
Kevlar Carbon style finish it's soft to
the touch it doesn't get cold so it is
pleasant but it will pick up I'll say
maybe grease fingerprints stuff like
that a little bit more
compared to the MacBook Pro which has an
easier hinge that opens up we still have
that all aluminum design which visually
looks more premium but it is a little
bit colder now there's also a difference
with this edge where this a little bit
softer so if you're typing for a long
time especially if you're sitting at a
desk it's gonna be a little more comfy
compared to this really kind of sharp
the sharp edges on the MacBook Pro as we
move on you're gonna see that these
laptops have more similarities than you
might think which definitely isn't a bad
thing starting off with fingerprint
sensors to login
we have touch ID for the MacBook Pro and
the windows hello fingerprint
authentication and right when we get to
the desktops probably the biggest thing
that you're gonna notice right away
looking at them is the difference in the
bezels so Dell once again has their
infinity bezel but now it might even be
thinner it's just incredible to look at
compared to the MacBook which
side-by-side looks a little bit old and
outdated both these also have 16 by 10
displays so Dell did change from a 16 by
9 to a 16 by 10 and that really helps
when you have a small display like these
13-inch displays now we also have a
difference in the actual panels so we
have a 2880 piano by 1600 on the MacBook
Pro which is kind of between 1080p and
4k vs. slightly higher than 4k with the
Dell XPS and it is also a touchscreen
now I'm personally not really into
touchscreen laptops but I'm also not
really into touch bars I only use the
macro cross touch bar when I absolutely
have to let's take a closer look at the
displays I have a video here ready to
watch so we can compare the quality but
before that I want to comment on the
brightness now both of these are maxed
out and they are very close I would say
the XPS is maybe slightly brighter but
you could probably say they're identical
and as far as the brightness shift even
though they're very similar when you're
looking right at them if you're looking
from the side the MacBook Pro has more
brightness shift so it gets dimmer if
you're looking off axis and maybe some
of the contrasts get a little bit washed
out as well
now the MacBook Pro does have true tone
turned on comparing the actual detail
from the displace it is hard to see on
standard webpages and your desktop
things like that if you're streaming a
4k video then you could tell that the
Dell is slightly more detailed they're
both 100% srgb and getting close to that
DCI p3 color reading so both very color
accurate the XPS is 4k display is also
HDR certified so it is playing back in
HDR now you also notice that we have a
little bit better contrast and that
Windows has not yet been activated on
this XPS right there at the bottom now
one thing that I should mention is that
with the Dell if you buy a lower end
model you will get a 1080p display
whereas with the MacBook Pros even if
you buy a base model it comes with the
same exact display on the plus side if
you have that 1080p display with this
new Intel chip you're gonna get roughly
2 ish hours better battery life than the
MacBook Pro which is already excellent
and with the 4k display they should be
quite similar I have to give a huge
thank you to Intel and microcell XPS
Micro Center has 25 stores nationwide
with an impressive amount of electronics
from gaming and VR computer parts like
processors graphics and everything else
needed to build a PC they also have a
huge variety of desktops laptops and all
the accessories that you need not only
that but also highly trained staff and
low prices check out a local Micro
Center today to get your hands on a
bunch of products before buying and you
can also go onto their website where you
can buy not only the Dell XPS
but also a wide variety of MacBook Pros
at great deals next let's look a little
bit lower to the keyboards and you're
probably gonna notice a couple of things
first off the Dell XPS keyboard looks
very similar to the MacBook Pros and
second on the MacBook Pro we have
speaker grilles on the side whereas the
smaller Dell XPS doesn't have anything
they actually stretched out the keyboard
made the keys larger with smaller gaps
in between which is awesome that's
actually what we were asking for but
there is no room for any speaker grille
if that means the speakers are actually
down firing so before we test out the
keyboards
let's go ahead and test out the speakers
[Music]
Wow there is definitely a huge
difference maca Pro is louder it also
has a lot more clarity now the XPS isn't
bad the sound quality is pretty decent
just doesn't have the volume that you
would want in louder environments now
back to the keyboards and as I mentioned
they are very similar they're both
really low-profile
both of them have backlighting but I
would have to say the Dell XPS s is a
little bit better even though our fans
of the MacBook Pros keyboard they both
have that really clicky type of field
but the Dell XPS has maybe close to
double the key travel or somewhere
around there so I think it's a perfect
blend of having a thin keyboard and
write between less standard one in the
MacBook Pros now if you move down to the
trackpad the MacBook Pro has an
excellent track but it's definitely
better you have even feel no matter
where you press because it uses magnets
you're not actually clicking whereas the
Dell so you do click but with that said
the Dell it has a larger trackpad than
before and it is one of the best windows
tracked as we were used and it's
actually usable instead of being
frustrating if you come from a MacBook
now finally it's time to talk about
specs and performance so we do have some
numbers for you guys but first off I'm
gonna let you know that both these have
one terabyte of nvme SSD storage and
also along with that they have i7
processors but the processors are quite
different and they both have Intel iris
+ graphics so it's great to see the
higher-end
integrated Intel chips being used in a
Windows laptop just like Apple does with
their MacBook Pros now this MacBook Pro
has a higher tier processor it's a 2.8
gigahertz that goes all the way to 4.7
that is the best one is offered in a
macbook pro compared to a 1.5 going up
to 3.8 with the dell XPS but you'll see
the performance numbers may show us a
bit of a difference other than just a
speck and that is because as I mentioned
at the start this Dell XPS is the first
laptop that has Intel's 10 nanometer
processor the ice Lake chip which gives
us better
see and performance per clock in
Geekbench for the multi-core score is
slightly higher with the MacBook Pro but
the single core is slightly higher with
the dell XPS but they are both very
close and if we compare the Intel iris
graphics the MacBook Pro is sitting out
50 mm which is crazy high for integrated
graphics compared to 39 thousand with
the Dell XPS now even though it's lower
in the XPS it is quite a huge
improvement compared to the previous XPS
laptops but we also have some numbers
with the newer Geekbench 5 which is
optimized for newer chips and here when
we compare it the XPS beats it beats out
the MacBook Pro in both the multi-core
and the single core and then if we take
a look at graphics performance with this
new test it's actually about 25% faster
so we have 10400 compared to 7500 so I'm
not sure what they did with the new
Geekbench 5 if it's more optimized or
it's more like an equal playing field or
what happened but this newer chip does
perform better along with that fan noise
is quite similar between the two and
it's nice to see a Windows laptop that
isn't screaming constantly as far as the
the stock thermal profile now another
huge difference between these two
laptops is the RAM our MacBook Pro has
16 gigabytes of lpddr3 RAM and that is
the most that you can get whereas the
Dell XPS not only does it use new lpddr4
Ram that is quite a bit faster but you
can also spec it out to 32 gigabytes of
RAM that's the models that we have so
for the same price point actually lower
I'll talk about that in just a sec you
can get that amount of RAM which is
impossible in a MacBook Pro now in order
to achieve this level of performance the
nice cooling that they have the thin and
light design and with 32 gigs of ram and
they'll have to change up the way they
did things so with this new XPS just
like with the macro you cannot switch
out your SSD your RAM your Wi-Fi chip or
anything else after you buy it so make
sure you spec it out the way that you're
going to need it just like if you were
gonna buy a MacBook Pro along with that
you know with the RAM with the new
processors the high-end graphics we also
have the latest Wi-Fi chip with Wi-Fi 6
and Bluetooth 5 so that is great time it
built-in you're not going to need to
swap that out so overall this really
packs a lot of performance you also have
a wide variety of configuration options
so this two in one with a 1080p screen
can be bought for as low as 999 dollars
whereas with a macbook pro if you get
the model of to thunder both reports
that is $1300 of course you can add on
you know better processors with better
graphics better display more storage
things like that and it does get up to
$2,700 MSRP both of these laptops are at
that price point but with the dell there
is constantly a ton of sales and deals
so right now a micro center you could
pick this up for roughly $500 off of
MSRP so it brings it to a much lower
price than the MacBook Pro even though
we have this new processor and double
the RAM so as far as value the Dell XPS
also provides a really good value now of
course we have the difference between
Windows and Mac OS I definitely prefer
Mac OS over Windows but that is going to
be up to you guys so overall I think the
Dell XPS is impressive we definitely
want the speakers to be better maybe the
trackpad to be improved if they could
but from all the Windows laptops that we
have tested this thing is probably the
best premium 13-inch laptop that you can
buy so let me know down in the comment
section below which one of these you
guys would buy and why once again a big
shout out to micro Center and Intel for
sending us this Dell XPS you guys want
to see the full review that is right
over there and click above to subscribe
and down below to enable notifications
there's been max max SEC and I will see
you in the next video
[Music]